le choc à Saint Bauer après la
découverte du corps d'un enseignant de
l'école primaire l'homme de 36 ans s'est
donné la mort par pendaison dans
l'enceinte de l'établissement où il
devait prendre ses nouvelles fonctions à
partir de lundi auparavant enseignant
dans le Vendôme moi rien au niveau
professionnel ne présageait un tel drame
selon la direction académique du
Loir-et-Cher Florent Clavel
je l'ai rencontré vendredi dernier il
avait l'air parfaitement bien jouant par
téléphone le maire de Saint Bauer
Bernard Pannequin était encore sous le
choc 24 heures après le suicide de cet
enseignant de 36 ans retrouvé pendus
sous le préau de l'école le choc mais
aussi l'incompréhension l'enseignant
s'est suicidé sur son lieu de travail
une symbolique forte pourtant tous les
indicateurs semblaient au vert indique
la directrice académique c'est
l'enseignant lui-même qui avait réclamé
sa mutation dans le Blois et saint
bohère effectivement c'était son choix
il était muté la Comté du 1er septembre
2023 à Saint Bauer à sa demande c'était
un de ses vœux visiblement il était
content d'être dans l'école il avait
même commencé déjà à travailler dans son
école lundi voilà lundi dernier pour sa
première rentrée dans cette école il
devait retrouver une classe de CE1 CM2
l'idée était pour lui de se recentrer
sur de travail d'enseignant après une
dizaine d'années passées notamment comme
directeur dans un établissement du vent
de moi où il avait d'ailleurs donné
entière satisfaction dans cette école il
était extrêmement reconnu il s'occupait
beaucoup des élèves il était aussi très
investi auprès de Lucette 41 qui est
donc l'association qui s'occupe d'animer
le sport scolaire dans le premier degré
et il s'engageait déjà à mettre des
actions en place dans le Blésois là où
il allait arriver après ce drame un
soutien psychologique va être mise en
place indique également la directrice
académique d'abord à destination du
personnel ici à saint-boer mais aussi
dans l'ancienne école du professeur à
Saint-Hilaire-la-Gravelle les élèves qui
l'ont connu font également l'objet d'une
vigilance particulière enfin un
enseignant remplaçant est attendu ici
lundi